Welcome back to Drew's News right here from Washington DC.
(cheering and applause)
Crazy!
I mean, The Lincoln Memorial!
I know, I know!
Well, before we go,
we'd love to leave you with a little something
to take with you in the doggy bag.
(magical twinkle)
(dog bark)
And here to curate, we've got a local DC style influencer,
and you can follow her @blonde_inthedistrict.
Please welcome Dani Sauter!
(applause)
Hi!
Thank you.
Oh my God.
Thank you so much for having me.
I'm so excited and I think it's amazing, the setup,
everything thank you for coming to DC. And, you know,
I started my blog because I wanted to show how style can
make you feel great about yourself and wearing something
amazing.
There's nothing better than like going out and wearing
something that you feel great in.
I mean, you put a smile on everyone's face
by what you're wearing and I'm glad to know
that it affects you positively too.
And what is your pick for the DC doggy bag?
A local dog and cat rescue organization
where my cats are from.
And I know that you have rescue animals as well,
so I thought that this would be a great topic to talk about.
I believe we both have rescue cats with the
same name.
Same name!
Yes, yes, absolutely.
Peaches!
Aw, cute.
Yes, yes. Isn't that so cute,
I feel like we're like kindred cat spirits.
We are.
Okay, so (laughs)
So it is a lost dog and cat rescue and that's actually
where Peaches and Pinky, they're mom and kitten,
they're so cute, are from,
and I recently adopted them this summer and I've adopted
from lost dog and cat before as well,
but, I really saw with this adoption,
everything that goes into running a rescue organization,
you know, rescue animals,
they bring so much joy to your life once you have them.
There is no question that when you rescue an animal,
they rescue you right back.
Absolutely.
And I'd like to make a $5,000 donation to that organization.
Oh my gosh, Drew!
(cheering)
Amazing, oh my gosh that is amazing, thank you.
I'm also going to call World's Best Litter,
a company I work with that is the leading donating company
of kitty litter to shelters in the country.
Yes.
(applause)
I actually, use their litter,
I saw that you, yes
Me too!
I saw that you use it too, the best litter ever,
and I have a little something for you guys, that I wanted to
So, inspired by cats,
I recently started my own vintage collection,
which is available on my website,
blondeinthedistrict.com.
And I have something, little gifts for both of you from,
Oh
So, okay Ross.
So this, I could see you wearing it on a blazer,
I know you like color.
Can I pull this off? Yes or no?
Yes
And Drew, I have the same earrings.
I actually found these as a pair and I figured that they
could be, I hope that when you wear them,
you think of your two rescue kitties and Peach and our
kindred cat spirits.
So we're like earing BFFs.
Thank you, Dani.
Thank you so much for having me!
Thank you.
(applause)
Let me see.
Oh look!
Cute.
Now we're twins!
We're twinning!
Thank you so much.
Thank you, Dani.
Thank you, seriously, for having me.
(upbeat drum music)